Peter like in a few days time no man's
sky next is upon us we've all been kind
of diving back into it and trying to
yeah but I thought to be interesting to
kind of look at the game as it is as it
stands right now and then in another
episode talk about a new no - guy next
that being said Peter you reviewed it if
you adhere to the direct path towards
the center of the galaxy in pursuit of
the games primary goal no man's sky
grows tiresome in less time than a game
with this much potential ought to the
last time you've played it was since
launched two years 2016 yeah last save
on PlayStation and I put in like 70 at
least 70 hours into that save I really
liked the game initially the Atlas path
which I heard has sort of been expanded
now yeah that really gave me a purpose
and sort of like added really
interesting context so like okay this is
a procedurally generated world what does
that mean not just as a video game but
as like a participant in this reality
that stuff was really cool you guys are
playing on PC and I want to play with
you with this new multiplayer patch so
I'm starting from scratch Wow
are the early hours of this game just
very isolating and kind of boring and
like I got through the first time
because it was all so new maybe it's
just unique to me because not many other
people will have to start from scratch
but as someone who is starting from
scratch it's like I really need other
people with me I really do at this point
I think that I'm just I'm I wasn't one
of the people who was upset about that
before that not being there but now that
I'm going through it again I really need
it so I hope it's as flexible and
enjoyable as I think it's gonna do it
and now you're just kind of bored doing
the exact same thing over and over again
yeah and you know the objectives are
sort of the same ones I've been through
and it's not even just the same intro
ones it's thing the game's objectives
tend to recycle quite a bit yeah
scavenge for materials build a thing
cool I've done that so many times
I've already been through the the wonder
of discovering new planets new galaxies
so so what I want now is like you know a
human foil to play off of to like crack
jokes with or you know you like make fun
of that stupid-looking animal in the
distance right
so just just make it make it an
experience that is before it was a
personal journey for me now I want it to
be a group effort or you know just
something that we can experience
together and really to form our own
stories with yeah yeah he does a very
tough beginning like I have been
complaining pretty incessantly about how
I don't think it's like very intuitive
in its tutorials because it'll tutorial
eyes some things they'll tell you how to
fuel your pulse thruster or how to
refill your life-support systems but
then it won't tell you that you can
summon your ship from anywhere on the
planet it won't tell you how this
currency or that currency works I feel
as if a lot of the way it repelled me
because I've only ever
I only ever played like 40 minutes of
the game back in 2016 now I've played
like maybe 12 in this last few days but
I didn't think it really is I got in I
felt like okay I see that there's like
survival elements to it but that just
like pushed me away immediately I wish
it would just throw you right in and
then kind of introduce those I think
it's a little better now it has that
awakening quest line yeah and you were
talking at the Atlas path I haven't had
to do too much that yet but the
awakening quest line at least kind of
feeds into a slugging to Jake it really
feeds into that mystery of the game
because I'm not like burnt out on just
finding new planets yet I think like I
am really excited for next because the
idea that you can like team up and just
make a force of pirates to mess with
everybody else is really appealing to me
kind of like see if thieves or what star
citizen was like aspiring to be back in
the day I don't know what's going on is
there any amount of PvP there is it's
it's not really quite explained well as
far as what they've released like
there's a brief brief list of notes
there's literally just a line it's like
you can join friends and stumble upon
random ones yeah even the trailer didn't
really make a lot of things that you
think would be clear but it's to what
you guys both saying is that you know
you have these aspects aspects of the
game that were slowly rolled out over
the course of two years which isn't
saying like the base building right now
there's now there's something you can
share
I wish we right you'll be able to build
them anywhere right you can build them
anywhere with no size limit either right
yeah there's a limit I think it's they
said that there are hundreds of new
pieces and the cap has been widened I
guess and it's funny because like
getting back into the game now like a
what uh several days before next comes
out it's such a weird thing that I'm
trying to justify in my head on the one
hand I'm enjoying more just chilling
with the game relaxing and not really
having an objective but on the other I
am kind of prepping myself to be able to
have all these objectives or at least
like these self created ones like again
I want to be a pirate and just take
other people's stuff and attack their
fleet with mine team up with three other
people maybe see their bases go back to
our hideout store all our stuff before
we go out another raid that's like the
dream of the game for me but at the same
time playing these last few days and
seeing how it's updated over the past
couple of years I've still had to come
to grips with the fact that the game
might not be as directed as I as a lot
of people thought it would be before it
came out but now that I see what it is
it's very relaxing it's very easy to
kind of chill out too and just enjoy the
pure exploration I do feel like the
survival gets in the way that sometimes
but the survival still you know I can't
complain too much about because it gives
me something to do and it gives me a
reason to go get oh I need iron to feel
my ship's thrusters right my pulse
thrusters or oh I need you know I need
plutonium to have enough you know
life-support to get to or to launch off
even get off the surface of that planet
so it's a weird I still feel like the
game is trying to be everything for
everybody right now and then that itself
is limiting it so I'm curious to see
whether next allows me to do that you
know that role-playing that I kind of
dreamed of when I first saw you know
footage of the game I I think it's still
gonna have like playing it now again
even with all these updates it's still
at its core the exact same game it was
at launch where yeah what you guys are
again saying is like you got to have
patience and you got to understand it's
a slow burn like seeing all these things
they've added like freighters right
it's like close to 160 million units it
takes a while to get to you're not gonna
just get these things quick so for for
people like you who are starting all
over again like you have to I just think
be really patient patient and just like
enjoy the mining aspect despite how like
like I was playing I got super lost just
like thinking oh I'm just gonna flip
Emeril all day and then like 30 minutes
later I only have a million units you
know I realize like I can't be doing
this so no if I can go through all that
again on my own and justify giving
myself up to the Hat
I did it once and it worked right but
right now it's just like okay we're
gonna play together that's what I'm
looking forward to so I still don't want
to like I don't hate the game but I'm
ready to like it again and it's gonna
take this patch I'm worried that I am
setting my expectations pretty high for
next and I'm cautiously optimistic that
it will be the thing to really make this
game what I wanted it to be well it's
hard to see what it's going to be yeah I
think it's gonna change the game in
unexpected ways it'll be a fun ride I'm
sure it'll be bit rocky but yeah I just
think ultimately if you didn't enjoy the
game at launch I love her slim yeah odds
are slim and I wouldn't be expecting
like the game they promised right I
think expectations were so high for this
game before release that
so what like a week from now we'll have
had a couple days experience with this
yeah that's right we'll come back see we
feel safe we'll still play so we're
still friends
thanks chiming guys maybe I'll be off
this goddamn planet by then
[Music]
you